in this month's so Vegas segment I'm
giving you a preview of a new one of a
kind epic experience at the Palms
there's a new status you can achieve in
Las Vegas
you know for example there's plenty of
high rollers but so far there's only one
Beast now we're at the 150k a night
hotel package at the Palms Hotel Resort
in Las Vegas yep you can go beast mode
at the Palms for an epic price now Mr
Beast is Infamous YouTuber and you know
he came to us and said we wanted we want
to put together something that's never
been done before and so when we started
to think well what does that mean what's
epic you know what better than three
Suites that don't exist anywhere else
the best Suites in the city and why not
have a dinner at one of the best
steakhouses in the world we'll get to
the stakes but first the sweets there
are three rooms of bowling themed room a
basketball theme room and an art themed
room with stuff from this famous artist
Damien Hurst which room do you two what
bowling yeah you sure yes nice choice
boys now it's not quite the Epic
experience package but I got a VIP tour
from The Palms VP of hospitality Kevin
glass so welcome to the Kingpin Suite
named after the classic film so this
read is fantastic it's about 4 500
square feet typically goes for fifteen
thousand dollars a night and in this
room you get two full bowling lanes
which is pretty cool we have a bowling
shoe room four queen size bunk beds a
pool table and then a master bedroom
course that comes with Butler service
and then we also offer complimentary
transportation from the airport to the
property this is a dream bathroom yeah
can you imagine taking a bath this view
uh
can so how many people can this
can the sweet fit so you can have up to
100 people in the room
um I think we could sleep more than 10
in here but you can sleep ten
comfortably okay that's fair at Kingpin
you've got bowling bubble baths and bunk
beds and guess what else you have
basketball but before you hit the
hardwood how about a ten thousand dollar
pregame meal wow yep the Epic experience
includes a feast fit for a beast well
besides you know having all the caviar
and all the crazy Seafood offerings and
um the the boutique wagyu collection
that we had we actually made them
chicken fingers and french fries to go
along with it there there's no request
too big or too small but besides any
special requests the package menu is
already epic an amuse Bush consisting of
wagyu and a caviar bite with a truffle
sauce a hot shellfish tower that is
flambe tableside to adito which is a raw
fish dish we have our wagyu beef
collection the cowboy A5 rib eye oh it's
been a beautiful little little meal you
know all right game time baby Welcome to
the hardwood Suite so the hardwood Suite
is just under 10 000 square feet it's a
two-story room of course it's got a half
basketball court
pool table Poker Room two master
bedrooms comes with Butler Service this
room has a hidden whiskey room which I'm
really excited to show you as well and
uh it comes with a full locker room so I
hope you're ready to shoot some hoops
later are we rolling just in case you
don't have enough bedrooms okay all
three of these little carve outs that
you see actually does
so you can sleep right on the basketball
court
so this is this is a whole new meaning
to ball is life that's right
now although basketball might be their
job I can imagine this is a baller's
paradise this is one of the most sought
after Suites by celebrities and
professional athletes
um rumor has it that several of them
have been here I know I know Shaq has
stayed here once or twice there's been
many more and to make your epic
experience official
it's got a score in the hardwood Suite
ready yep
come on
nice
yeah I'm ready to move into you guys saw
that yeah
The Palms epic experience package is
ready to book right now but it's only
available from January 8th through
October 8th of 2023 so it's epic it's
expensive and it's exclusive we will
have all that information